Build it.
Draw it.
Play it.
Vsauce!
This is your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people.
This is BiDiPi.
Build it
Artist Ron Mueck builds lifelike sculptures
of human figures out of silicone, polyester
resin, fiberglass, and synthetic hair that
range in size from miniature to larger than
life.
His work is unveiling new work for the first
time since 2005 in Paris starting in April
and his art can also be seen at the art show
Life like at the museum of contemporary art
in san diego.
Alice Finch from Seattle built this Huge LEGO
rendition of the Hogwarts School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry.
It took her 12 months and around 400,000
bricks to complete and is built in a L shape
where each side is about 13 feet long.
She took home both best in show and peoples
choice award at BrickCon 2012.
Knitter stream is an electronic knitting machine
from 1998 that transforms tweets into real
woven works of art using custom software and
hardware.
Launched at the festival C2-MTL, where people
were asked to tweet using hash tag knitter
stream and the most retweeted ones were knit
into 120 feet of custom designs.
Draw It
After drawing his own likeness on a peanut,
Steve Casino got the idea to start painting
celebrities he admired onto them.
He cracks them open and removes the nuts,
then glues the shell back together, fills
the front with wool filler and sands them
down.
Then he adds legs and paints them, which can
take up to 10 hours, and finally adds the
arms.
He leaves the back untouched because he loves
the reactions he gets when he turns it around
to reveal a detailed painting.
Sandra is a self educated makeup artist from
Sweden that does very creative and impressive
makeup work.
Some of her looks include this realistic drawn
eyeball on lips, custom girl mustache, decaying
wounds, eye hearts, and this great timon from
the lion king makeup.
And now for the the legion of real life super
heroes by Butcher Billy where real life bad
guys become comic book villains.
Play it
Mike Wilson aka Coma Niddy is a New York based
educator and rapper.
Here is is song he did about Anti Matter.
Here is the official music video for "A taste
of struggle" by ATOS created by Simon Mannaerts
Using the Makey Makey described in episode
7 of Vsauce 3 Game LUT, electronic music producer
j. viewz recreates the song teardrop by Massive
Attack with a well picked out assortment of
fruit.
Submit your own BiDiPis as a personal message
here on YouTube.
Or share them with everyone at facebook.com/vsaucetwo.
Click here to listen to bidipi radio.
Music created and submitted by you guys.
Also check out Your BiDiPi - an entire video
dedicated to your creations.
And as always... thanks
for watching.